The name Ilio is a revival of the Greek
name for the sun god Helios. So I don't
think it's coincidence when the main
protagonist whose name means the sun god
has one eye covered which happens to be
the Egyptian symbol of the sun god raw.
We see Ilio approach some flying cards.
They're in the shape of an oraoris. Four
cards are displayed each with a sigil on
them. A sigil in the occult is a magical
symbol used to invoke spirits, manifest
desired outcomes, and harness energy.
This is divination. Ilio actively seeks
contact, crafting a ritual display with
a giant sigil and a plea. Aliens, abduct
me. I'm trying to get abducted by
aliens. When the aliens come to abduct
him, his reaction is excitement and
glee. It's really happening. This is
literally grooming children into the new
age and teaching them how to summon
nonhuman entities which are literally
demonic beings.